[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليال اختيار استهلها بابره
العناو
موسكو تتهم الغرب بمحاوله احداث تمرد مسلح
داخل روسيا وتوريث الشباب الرصيفي الارهاب
مع استمرار التدريبات العسكريه الصينيه
المكثفه تحذيرات من غزو صيني محتمل
لتايوان
اليوم الخميس يوم 13 من هذا الشهر اول يوم
سوف يكون هنالك عمليه تبادل بين صنعاء
وعدم فراشه مرتقبه للازمه اليمنيه تبادل
الاسرى بين الشرعيه والحوثيين يبدا الخميس
والاطباء في بريطانيا يبداون اضرابا جديدا
للمطالبه برفع اجورهم مئات الاف المواعيد
معلقه
[موسيقى]
في احدث فصول الازمه بين روسيا والغرب
اتهامات للاخير بمحاوله تدبير تمرد مسلح
داخل روسيا وتحريض جيل الشباب من الروس
على الانخراط في انشطه ارهابيه ومتطرفه
على حد تعبير موسكو هذا اول ملفات التاسعه
[موسيقى]
مع رئيس جهاز الامن الروسيه الكسندر
بورنيكوف اتهم كلا من اوكرانيا ودول
الغربيه بمحاوله تحريض الروس على تخريب
والتمرد المسلح على خلفيه غزو اوكرانيا
مؤكدا انا اجهزه الامن الاوكرانيه اطلقت
مع قادتها الغربيين حمله ايديولوجيه
وتجنيديه عدوانيه تستهدف فيها الروس
وخصوصا جيل الشباب وقال ان هذه الحمله
تهدف الى توريط الروس في انشطه تخريبيه
وارهابيه متطرفه في روسيا
للحديث اكثر عن هذا الملف تنضم الينا من
موسكو الينا سوبولينا المستشاره السياسيه
في مركز الدراسات الدوليه اهلا وسهلا بك
استاذه الينا يعني ما قبل الحرب ومنذ
بدايه الحرب هناك حاله اعتراضيه موجوده
داخل موسكو وجرى اسكاتا باكثر من مناسبه
ان كان اعلاميا ان كان سياسيا وان كان
شعبيا اليوم الحديث عن مؤامره غربيه
اوكرانيه للتاثير على الداخل اليس فيها
نوع من التعبئه على هذه الحاله الموجوده
اصلا
مساء الخير ورمضان كريم تصريحات رئيس
الاستخبارات الروسيه سيد بورد فتاتي
كتعبير عن قلق متزايده لدى اجهزه الامن
الروسيه ولكن البعض ينظر لمطلع هذه
التصريحات كنوع من الاعتراف انه الاختراق
الغربي والاوكراني واصبح خطيرا جدا ودليل
على ذلك عده عمليات ارهابيه
تمت بيد ارهابيين اوكرانيا او اكثر خطوره
الروس تم تجنيدهم من قبل اوكرانيا
وهذه الحاله هي ان تتطور لانه اذا اخذنا
اختيار داريا بنت فيلسوف الكسندر الشهير
في السن الماضي فتم هذا الشيء بيد
اوكرانيا ارهابيه اوكرانيه اما
اغتيال
مدون روسي شهير
معروف بلقب تم اختياره بيد بنت روسيه تم
تجنيدها من قبل الاجهزه لكن هذا موجود
عاده بالحروب
منظومه اوكرانيه متطرفه عاده بالحروب
التجنيد يعني داخل الدول موجود وهو ليس
بالجديد هي نوع من اداه حرب موجوده ان كان
عند الجانب الروسي وان كان عند الجانب
الاوكراني وبالتالي يعني هو ليس الموضوع
والهدف بحد ذاته انما وجود روسيين اليوم
قابلين للتعاطي والتعامل مع الاوكران يعني
بانهم لديهم وجهه نظر مختلفه عن وجهه نظر
الكريم وهم غير راضيين عن هذه الحرب هذه
الظاهره بحد ذاتها الى ماذا ترمس
انا اولا لا اعتقد ان هناك
اكثريه الاسباب هي اسباب ايديولوجيه لانه
بعض الحالات تمت اعلانها من قبل اجهزه
الامن الروسيه الى
العلاقه بشراء بعض الناس لديهم رغبه في
التعاون او في تقديم معلومات حساسه لطرف
العدو ونفس الشيء تعمل الان الاستخبارات
الروسيه عندما تجند بعد الاوكران فلا شك
ولكن
اغتيال المدون في بدايه ابريل نعم يشير
الى حاله خطيره جدا ان هناك اساس
ايديولوجي
لتجنيد بعض الشباب
وهم يعترضون على هذه العمليه العسكريه
لكنني لا اعتقد انه عدده او لا هو كبير
سيده علينا يعني هناك جزء كبير من الحرب
اليوم بموازاه الحرب العسكريه هي الحرب
النفسيه الدائره بين كل من الغرب الولايات
المتحده واوكرانيا وروسيا اليوم التهويل
بموضوع يعني الاختراق الكبير للداخل
الروسي خصوصا وان هناك قناه على لدى الغرب
بان لا مجال لانهاء هذه الحرب بدون انهاء
وانهاء بوتين بذاته لان حرب بوتين وليست
حرب روسيا
التهويل بهذا الموضوع على يدخل ضمن هذه
الحرب الحرب النفسيه طبعا
نعم هناك بعض المحللين الغربيين وايضا بعض
المعارضين الروس الذين موجودين بالغرب من
هم مثلا ميخائيل خضر كوفسكي هم يتكلمون
يوميا حول ضروره تغيير النظام في روسيا
ولكنهم لا يفهمون انه هذه الاحاديث هم
بالعكس
يساعدون على تقويه مواقف رئيس بوتين لانه
شعور معادله للغرب شعور معاديه لامريكا هي
منتشره في داخل روسيا وعندما ياتي الحديث
عن تغيير النظام فبالعكس الناس هم يلتفون
حول القياده ليش لان روسيا لديها تاريخ
بما فيها تاريخ دموي كانت هناك الثوره
ثوره البلاشفه وكانت لم تدخلوا انتم ايضا
بهذه الحضاريخ الحرب النفسيه اتحدث عبر
عبر الحديث عن ان هناك يعني تجنيد كبير في
الداخل وان هناك استعمال للداخل لمحاوله
زعزعه امن استقرار روسيا وما الى هناك
والله ما اقولها انه بالعكس ناس هم
متخوفين من سيناريو الازمه الداخليه ولا
يريدون تكرار الحرب الاهليه في داخل روسيا
كما لا يسمحون باي تدخلات غربيه في داخل
روسيا فانا اصلا مستغربه من تصريحات رئيس
الاستخبارات الروسيه السيده بورتنيكا كانه
هدف من هذه التصريحات هو تعبير عن قلق
ورغبه في
توحيد صفوف المجتمع ولكنني اتفق معكم بانه
بعض الاحيان نتائج مثل هذه التصريحات ممكن
ان تكون عكسيه شكرا لك سعيده الينا
سوبونينا المستشاره السياسيه في مركز
الدراسات الدوليه حدثنا من موسكو
على صعيد اخر نقلت صحف صحيفه امريكيه عن
وثائق مسربه احتماليه سيطرت روسيا على
اجواء اوكرانيا وبالتالي خساره اوكرانيا
لمعركه السماء وفقدان السيطره على اجوائها
ابتداء من منتصف الشهر الحالي الى مايو
المقبل
مسار الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه قد يتغير
الشهر المقبل والسبب نقص المعدات الجويه
العسكريه عند قوات كيف ازمه الاوكرانيه
تلوح في الافق لكن من صالح روسيا التي قد
تحقق امكانيه الهيمنه على السماء اوكرانيا
وفق صحيفه
نقلا عن وثائق امريكيه عسكريه مسربه تحدي
كبير تواجهه الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
لنفاد الذخيره والصواريخ المضاده للطائرات
تحديدا الذخيره المصممه بطريقه صافيه
لانظمه الدفاع الجوي الخاصه بها
حسب الوثائق السريه ستستنفذ اوكرانيا
بالكامل مخزونه من صواريخ بحلول منتصف
ابريل والصواريخ اس 300 اضافه الى
بطاريتين من طراز
وبطاريه واحده للدفاع الجوي ايروس تي
بحلول ماي وفق الصحيفه اذا تم نفاذ هذه
المعدات العسكريه ستصبح معظم البودى
التحتيه الحيويه الاوكرانيه الواقعه خارج
منطقه كييف ومنطقتين اخرىين في جنوب غرب
اوكرانيا من دون غطاء للدفاع الجوي بعدد
مواقع حساسه غير محميه يبلغ 40 بدلا من
سته
وفقا لاحدى الوثائق النتيجه المحتمله
لازمه الدفاع الجوي قد تفقد الجيش
الاوكراني القدره على حشد قواته البريه
بالقرب من الخطوط الاماميه وشن الهجوم
المضاد المقرر في الاسابيع المقبله واقع
لا يغيره السوى وفاء الدول الغربيه
بوعدها بتسريح كيف
الوثائق الامريكيه السريه المصربه انتشرت
عبر عده تطبيقات بمواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وعلى راسها تطبيق يسمى ديسكورد فما هو هذا
التطبيق وكيف كان يستخدم عند تتشينه
فلنتابع
ديسكورد تطبيق امريكي للدردشه بالكتابه
والصوت والفيديو ينشط عليه 150 مليون
مستخدم شهريا وتبلغ قيمته 14 مليار و700
مليون دولار عمر المنصه ثمان سنوات وتحظى
بشعبيه كبيره بين الشباب ورواد العاب
الفيديو وثائق البنتاجون المسربه تم
تداولها على المنصه بدايه مارس قبل ظهورها
على مواقع اخرى ديسكورد نعمل مع السلطات
الامريكيه فيما يتعلق بوثائق البينتاجون
المسربه
اقر مجلس النواب الروسي انشاء نظام
الكتروني لتوجيه مذكرات الاستدعاء الخاصه
بالتجنيد الاجباري للشباب المطلوبين
للتجنيد بدلا من خطابات الاستدعاء التي
كانت تسلم سابقا باليد الامر الذي من شانه
تسهيل عمليه انضمام
المجندين الى صفوف الجيش بعد دخول الهجوم
الروسيه لاوكرانيا عامه الثاني ووافق
الدمى الروسي بالاجماع على تشريع القرار
في القراءه الثانيه الرئيسيه
افادت وكاله نقلا عن ثلاثه مصادر ببدء
روسيا نقل مشتقات البنزين والوقود الى
ايران عبر سكك الحديديه وقالت المصادر ان
الصادرات الروسيه الى ايران بدات للمره
الاولى في وقت سابق من هذا العام مضيفين
ان ذلك هدفه تنويع موسكو لامداداتها من
المنتجات النفطيه في ظل العقوبات المفروضه
عليها
[موسيقى]
التوتر العسكري بين تايوان والصين يتفاقم
وسط مخاوف من سيناريوهات عده لاحتماليه
غزو الصين لتايوان هل سيتم عبر حصار مشدد
ام هجوم كاسه هذا هو السؤال الاساسي اليوم
في تقرير لصحيفه التايمز البريطانيه يشير
الى ان مثل هذا التحرك العسكري لبكين له
تداعيات ابعد من الجزيره قد تجتذب الى
صراع قوى عظمى او حتى لسيناريو اسوا اي
حرب نوويه لكن يبقى السيناريو المنتظر هل
تغزو بكين بالفعل ام لا وفقا لمحللين
عسكريين مشاهدينا فان سيناريو الغزو امر
متوقع لكنه سيكون من المستحيل اطلاق الغزو
على حين غره او على بفجاه طبعا حيث
سيستغرق الصين وستستغرق الصين اسابيع
لتتجمع في الموانئ الصينيه على مراى ومسمع
من اقمار التجسس الغربيه
الحصار يمكن ان يبدا ببطء وبشكل خفيف دون
ان يلاحظ احد وقد يمتد لشهور او سنوات
يمكنك ذلك ان يبدا حصار تايوان بتدريبات
عسكريه طبعا على غرار التي تم اجراؤها على
مدى اشهر بقطع حركه المرور الجويه
والبحريه والبريه للجزيره كما اصبح معلوما
مع عمليات تفتيش صينيه الزانيه صحيفه
الفرنسيه اشارت الى سيناريو اخر يتضمن
هجوما صينيا يستهدف الجزر التايوانيه
الاقرب للبر الرئيسي للصين لكن صعوبه هذا
السيناريو تتمثل في الهبوط في تايوان
نفسها خاصه مع انظمه دفاع متطوره قدمتها
الولايات المتحده للاخيره الى جانب
استراتيجيه بكين العسكريه نحو حصار طويل
الامد تتعمد الصين استخدام حرب نفسيه تهدف
طبعا لاحباط عزيمه سكان تايوان على المدى
الطويل وهي لاستراتيجيه التي تفضلها بكين
حسب العديد من الخبراء
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من
الصحافه نادي الرانج للحديث اكثر عن
سيناريو حصار الجزيره او الغزو العسكري
استاذ نادر يعني اليوم دعنا نتحدث عن
سيناريو الحصار سيناريو الحصار سيرهق
الاقتصاد العالمي كما سيرهق الاقتصاد
الصيني عبر شل سلاسل التوريد عبر زياده
الشحن وطبعا اشباه الموصلات وكل الصناعات
الاخرى التي ستتاثر هل يعني الصين جاهزه
لهكذا خطوه
اهلا ومرحبا بكم هذه
يعني اولا الصين ما زالت تتماسك
يعني التوحيد السلمي كالخيار الاول
يعني تنفيذ مهمه توحيد كامل للبلاد
واذا كان هناك العوده الى مبدا سنه واحد
من قبل السلطه في تايلاند وكذلك التماسك
بمبدا سن واحد لن يكون هناك اي يعني
التسعيد او اي المحاكاه المنوعات او
حتى باستخدام
ولكن اذا هناك الاستمرار في السعي الى
الاستقلال
الصين الرئيسي وجيش تحرير الشعب الصيني
مستعد لتنفيذ مهمه التوحيد البلاد
باي ثمن كان
المتحده الاخيره انتقلت من مرحله او من
سياسه الغموض الاستراتيجي الى سياسه
الوضوح الاستراتيجي مع ما يعنيه من سياسات
من تثبيت لسياسه الردع وخصوصا بمنطقه
الهادئ
الصين اليوم حتى وان كان يعني المسار
الانفصال
ستكمله تايوان ماذا يعني ذلك من تدخل
الولايات المتحده لليابان وغيره من
الحلفاء بهذه الحرب
يمكن ان نرى المناورات التي ترجعها القوات
المسلحه الصينيه هو
اكبر يعني هدف هو من اجل الرد التدخلات
العسكريه محتمله من قبل القوات الامريكيه
وكذلك اليابانيه
فكلنا نعلم اذا كان لا يوجد
الولايات المتحده او قوه امريكيه في هذه
المنطقه
المساله قد يعني حره منذ وقت طويل فكلما
اذا كان البارك اراد التوحيد فهناك
الكسور يعني الاسطور السابع الامريكيه يقف
امام
ذلك ولكن الان لذلك الحدث الرئيسي من
الجيش الشعبي الصيني وتدو
العسكريه هو من اجل الدفاع عن سياده الصين
الوطني
الدفاع عن السياده وحمايه الامن القومي هي
نفس العناوين التي استخدمتها روسيا بحربها
الاخيره اليوم في حال دخلت الصين بهذه
الحرب الا تخاف من حرب استنزاف كما دخلت
روسيا بحرب يعني طبعا الظروف مختلفه ولكن
اتحدث عن العناوين التي استخدمت مع
التاثيرات العسكريه والجيوستراتيجيه طبعا
على الصين
اولا
الامر مختلفه لان هنا التنفيذ التوحيد هو
الجزم من الاراضي الصينيه وهذا اعترف بها
القرارات مجلس الامن والامم المتحده وحتى
الولايات المتحده بذلك فهي ليست الدوله
وثم
القوات
العسكريه
جدا
كذلك الجزيره هو يعني هي الجزيره
وثم الاعلان لدى جيش تحرير الشعبي نقاطع
جميل امدادات الاسلحه الى المنخارجه الى
التايلاند وكذلك امدادات
وكذلك
الحروب للاتصاليين في تايلاند فالامر
مختلف تماما شكرا لك استاذ نادر رانج
حدثتنا من بكين
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا التاسع مستمره وفي بعد قليل
يحذر ديسنتوس من الترشح للرئاسه ويتهمه
بشق صف الحزب الجمهوري
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت الحكومه اليمنيه
بدا عمليه تبادل الاسرى والمعتقلين مع
الحوثيين الخميس المقبل ولمده ثلاثه ايام
اشهر الفريق الحكومي بالمفاوضات الى ان
عمليات تبادل اسره ستشمل رحلات جويه بين
العاصمه صنعاء وعده ومناطق وعدن ومناطق
اخرى في اليمن بتنسيق مع اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر كما اكد ان الاستعدادات
اكتملت
صنعت الجهود الدبلوماسيه الاخيره والحراك
السياسي بقياده السعوديه ودول كبرى في
المنطقه تفاؤلا بمرحله جديده سمتها
الاستقرار وتغليب المصالح على الصراع
السياسي والعسكري فلنتابع
حراك سياسي قوي في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
المتوتره على كثير من الجبهات تقوده
السعوديه والدول الكبرى في المنطقه في
مسعا لاطفاء كثير من الحرائق التي ظلت
مشتعله لسنوات
عاد الضوء الى طاولات الحوار بدءا بتهدئه
التوتر بين عدد من دول المنطقه وتركيا
مرورا بلقاءات بين القيادات السياسيه
وانتهاء بالاتفاق مع انقره على ايجاد سبل
لحل الملفات او تهدئه حده الصراع في سوريا
وليبيا
العاشر من مارس شهد ايضا ولاده لاتفاق بين
السعوديه وايران برعايه صينيه بعد قطيعه
امتدت لنحو سبع سنوات اعطت املا بظهور
نتائج ايجابيه على ملفات عده بالمنطقه
كسوريا والعراق ولبنان واليمن الخطوه
الاخيره في سلسله التهدئه جاءت من اليمن
بعد زياره وفدي السعوديه وعمان لصنعاء
ولقائهما بقياده الحوثيين وبحث الوصول الى
الحل السياسي عبر عده مراحل يؤمل منها
اعاده الاستقرار الى اليمن بعد ثمان سنوات
من الحرب الدائره هناك
المسارات الدبلوماسيه التي انتهجتها دول
المنطقه صنعت تفاؤلا بمرحله جديده سم تها
الاستقرار وتغليب المصالح الاقتصاديه
والتنمويه على الصراع السياسي والعسكري
ولقيت اشاده دوليه واماميه
[موسيقى]
يباشر الاف الاطباء الشباب في بريطانيا
اضرابا مدته اربعه ايام للمطالبه باجور
افضل في خضم ازمه غلاء معيشه ما يزيد طبعا
من الضغوط على النظام الصحي في البلاد
اضرابهم قد يشمل القطاع الصحي بشكل كامل
ووفقا للاتحاد للاتحاد الخدمات الصحيه
الوطنيه هناك نحو 350 الف موعد طبي قد
يؤجل بما في ذلك طبعا العمليات الطبيه
وسبق للاطباء مشاهدينا طبعا الاطباء
الشباب ان اضربوا مده ثلاثه ايام الشهر
الماضي ما اثر على 175 الف موعد فيما حذر
هنا الرئيس التنفيذي لاتحاد هيئه الخدمات
الصحيه الوطنيه من التاثير المحتمل
للاضراب ووصفه بالمفجع ودعا كلا الجانبين
الى انهاء هذه المعركه صحيفه غاردين
بريطانيه وصفت الاضراب الاخير بالاخطاء
حيث يعد هذا اطول اضراب في الخدمه الصحيه
منذ ان اتخذ الممرضين والتواقم الطبيه
والاسعاف وغير هؤلاء من العاملين الصحيين
اجراءات مماثله العام الماضي
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من لندن مصطفى زارو
مراسل العربيه مصطفى يعني بظل تدهور
القيمه قيمه
كل معاشات القطاع الصحي هناك والمطالبات
التي تصفها الحكومه بانها نوعا ما غير
واقعيه ما الذي سيحصل وما هو وضع القطاع
الصحي بالايام المقبله بوصف الاضراب
التضخم وخاصه ان رفع الاجور سيزيد منها
وبالتالي قالت بان يجب ان تكون هذه
الزياده تتماشى مع التسويات التي عقدتها
الحكومه مع مثلا
للمسعفين للممرضين بان هذه الزيادات يعني
لا تتجاوز تقريبا سته في المئه خمسه فاصله
خمسه في المئه بالاضافه الى علاوات اخرى
يعني تدفع مره واحده وهذا بالطبع يعني
هو قليل بالنسبه الى حجم التضخم الذي
شهدناه في البلاد بسبب الارتفاع الكبير
للاسعار وبالاضافه ايضا الى ربما السياسه
التقشفيه انتاجات الحكومات الماضيه في
قطاع الصحه مما ادى الى تراجع القيمه
الفعليه لرواتب هؤلاء مصطفى يعني الاطباء
المتدربين او ما يعرف هناك بالجنر دكتورز
يمثلون اكثر من نصف الاطباء بالمستشفيات
البريط انيه اضراب هؤلاء ماذا يعني على
القطاع الصحي نتحدث عن ثلاثه الى اربعه
ايام يعني هو كثير جدا
السلطات الصحيه وضعت اجراءات طارئه
للتعامل مع هذا الاضراب الذي تم يعني
الوصول الى نتيجته يعني بطريقه سريعه جدا
ولكن نصف الاستشاريين الذين يعملون مع
هؤلاء الاطباء هم يعني يوافقون على هذا
الاضراب ولكن في نفس الوقت انهم سيعملون
على تغطيه جزء من عملهم بالاضافه الى
الاستعانه السلطات المحليه باطباء الاسر
بالاضافه الى الصيدليون ايضا سيعملون مع
مختلف المستشفيات لتخفيف معاناه المرضى
وايضا تقديم ما يلزم من العنايه اليهم
وبالتالي هذه بعض الاجراءات التي اتخذتها
خدمات الصحه الوطنيه في مواجهه مخاطر هذا
الاضراب وان سيكون له عواقب يعني كبيره
نسبه الى القوائم الانتظار التي وهي اكثر
من سبعه ملايين شخص ينتظرون يعني
معاينه الطبيب او اجراء عمليه او فحوصات
معينه بالاضافه الى ان
يعني خلال هذه المده يمكن ان تستعين خدمات
الصحه الوطنيه بعدد محدود من هؤلاء
المضربين الاطباء المضربين عن العمل في
حالات استثنائيه مثل ما شهدنا او تابعنا
ان مستشفى في في جنوب في واستن في جنوب
غرب البلاد يعني استعان ببعض هؤلاء من
المضربين نفس الشيء لاحظناه ايضا عندما
كان هناك اضراب للمسعفين يعني خلال
اعتصامهم نشهد خروج
احد هؤلاء لتقديم يعني اسعافات ضروريه او
التوجه الى مكان اتصال مريض انه وبالتالي
ربما هذه من الاجراءات ايضا التي وضعت في
ش روط الدخول في اضراب كهذا شكرا لك مصطفى
زار ومراسل العربيه حدثنا من لندن
[موسيقى]
عثرات السلطات في ايرلندا الشماليه على
اربع قنابل انبوبيه من مقبره في منطقه
كراجن خلال عمليه اجرتها الشرطه للتاكد من
السلامه العامه في البلاد قبيله ساعات من
وصول الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الى
ايرلندا الشماليه واعرب بهذا الشان مساعد
قائد الشرطه بابي سينجل تون قلقه من
القنابل الانبوبيه واصفا اكتشافها بالتطور
المشؤوم
تداعياته تسريبات الوثائق الامريكيه لا
زالت تتوالى عشرات الوثائق كشفت وكشفت عن
خطط امريكا مستقبلا وكشفت ايضا عن تجسس
الولايات المتحده على بعض الدول فلنتابع
تسريبات من اروقه البنتاغون الى العالم
كشفت عم تخططه امريكا كما كشفت اختراق
احدى عشر دوله بدءا من الصين الى هايتي في
هذه الوثيقه ما يدل على ان الصين تحت
المجهر تتجسس امريكا على عدوتها اللدود
فهنا وثائق تضمنت تحليلا للمخاطر الصينيه
واسعه النطاق واستعداد بكين لارسال
مساعدات فتاكه الى روسيا وتفاصيل اختبار
تجريبي لصاروخ نووي يفوق سرعه الصوت
تسريبات كشفت ايضا ان امريكا تمارس ضغوطا
على كوريا الجنوبيه في حثها لارسال
مساعدات عسكريه الى اوكرانيا في وقت تتخوف
سول من غضب موسكو وثيقه اخرى كشفت مساعي
اسرائيل لتزويد اوكرانيا بنظام دفاع جوي
سبايدر سام اضافه الى صواريخ جافل المضاده
للدروع بينما يتضح هنا ان روسيا تزود
ايران بطائرات سوخوي 35 ونظام دفاع جوي
وقدرات صاروخيه الوثيقه عرجت ايضا على قلق
اسرائيل الشديد من التقارب العسكري بين
روسيا وايران مجموعه باجنال الروسيه
طالتها نار التسريبات ايضا فضحت احدى
الوثائق مخططه فاجنر للسفر الى هايتي
والتعاون رسميا مع عصابات مسلحه متهمه
بقضايا قتل واختطاف مسلسل التسريبات لا
تزال تحليلاته مستمره عالميا ما يضع
الولايات المتحده امام حرج سياسي وعسكري
قد يغير الحسابات مستقبلا غذاء السالم
العربيه
حصل الكونغرس الامريكيه على وثائق سريه
عثر عليها في الممتلكات الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن ورئيس السابق دونالد ترامب ونقلت
وكاله بلومبرغ عن مصدر مطلع ان مجموعه من
كبار المشارعين في الكونجرس سيمكنهم فحص
الوثائق السريه مشيرا الى ان تلك المجموعه
بالكونغرس مختصه بالوصول الى معلومات
استخباراتيه حساسه
مع صعود نجم حاكم فلوريدا رانديسنتس كمرشح
للرئاسه في عام 2004 24 الرئيس السابق
دانيل ترامب وجه تهديدا لاذعا للاخير عبر
منصه تروس سوشيال ميديا وحذره من ان ترشحه
يعني انقسام الحزب الجمهوري وخساره منصب
حاكم فلوريدا والرئاسه هجوم ترامب على
منافسه الجمهوريه سبقه بيان صحفي تطرقت في
حمله ترامب الى ما اذا كان ديسنتس يؤيد
تغيير قوانين قانون فلوريدا الذي يتطلب من
نواب الولايه الاستقاله اذا كانوا يترشحون
لمنصب فيدرالي واشارت حمله ترامب الى ان
قرار ديسنت الاستقاله من الكونغرس في عام
2018 اثناء الترشح لمنصب حاكم فلوريدا مما
يشير الى انه سيكون من النفاق بالنسبه له
ان لا يفعل الشيء نفسه هذه المره وحتى
اللحظه لم يعلن دي سنه الترشحه من عدمه
الا ان مصادر ذهيل الامريكيه اشارت الى
انه كان يستعد بهدوء بجمع موظفين بعضهم
عمل لصالح ترامب سابقا وتعيين مجموعه
مؤيده خارجيه والسفر طبعا لعده ولايات
للتصويت المقبل المبكر قبيله الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
المانيا تودع الطاقه النوويه نهائيا قرار
شجاع لبرين في ظل اعتماد الكثير من الدول
الغربيه على الطاقه النوويه اذ تتوقف
السبت المقبل اخر ثلاثه مفاعلات معوله على
انجاح انتقالها من دون الاعتماد على
الطاقه الذريه تلك المفاعلات تتوزع على
ثلاثه مواقع محطه بادن فورتنبرغ للطاقه
النوويه ومجمعي اثار تو بمنطقه بافاريا
شرقيه البلاد وامزلوند شمالا في الطرف
الاخر من المانيا قرب الحدود الهولنديه
تنفذ المانيا قرار التخلص التدريجي من
الطاقه النوويه المنتخب عام 2002 والذي
سرعته انجيلا ميركل في عام 2011 بعد كارثه
فوكوشيما في اليابان قرار حظي يا مشاهدينا
حينها بتاييد واسع لكن قبل اشهر قليله من
الموعد المبدئي لاغلاق المفاعلات بدات
رياح الراي العام تتحول وقررت حكومه اولفش
لز الذي ينضوا فيها حزب الخضر الاكثر عداء
للطاقه النوويه تمديد تشغيل المفاعلات
لتامين الامدادات حتى الخامس عشر من ابريل
القادم اي الموعد النهائي للايقاف
[موسيقى]
التاسع مستمره فيها بعد قليل
عشرات الالاف يتوافدون الى الحرم المكي في
اول ايام العشر الاواخر من رمضان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في اول ايام العشر
الاواخر من شهر رمضان يتوافد الاف
المعتمرين والزوار للمسجد الحرام بمكه
لاداء سلطيه التراويح والتهجد واعلنت
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين عن جاهزيه التوسعه
لاستقبال المصلين في سلطي التراويح
والقيام من خلال عدد من الخدمات
والتجهيزات الميدانيه والهندسيه والفنيه
وتشغيل الاف الكوادر البشريه على مدار
الساعه من اجل راحه وسلامه المعتمرين
والزوار
[موسيقى]
معنى من الحرم المكي مراسل العربيه اسامه
القاسم اسامه كيف هي الصوره باول ايام
العشر الاواخر من رمضان
اهلا وسهلا العيال تحيه طيبه لكم ولجميع
مشاهدين العربيه نعمل
من التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه وهي تتسع
لاكثر من مليون و200 الف مصلي في الساعه
نتحدث اليوم عن هذه التوسعه التي تستقبل
الزوار وقاصدين مسجد الحرام في اولى ايام
العشر الاواخر والعشرين اليوم الماضي من
شهر رمضان المبارك اترككم الان عبر كاميرا
العربيه في صوره مباشره لاعداد المصلين في
التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه طبعا التوسعه
السعوديه الثالثه تستقبل كما سبقت اكثر من
مليون و200 الف زائر ومصلي ومعتمر خلال
ايام شهر رمضان المبارك نتحدث اليوم ايضا
عن الخدمات المتواجده هنا في التوسعه
السعوديه الثالثه عدد المصاعد فيها قرابه
ال 26 مصعد عدد السلالم الكهربائيه 346
سلم عدد المشربيات اللي سقيا زمزم حوالي
675 مشربيه عدد الحافظات 12 الف حافظه
وعدد الابواب 80 باب نتحدث ايضا عن دورات
المياه التي تتجاوز الاربعه الاف وثمانمئه
دوره مياه وايضا دورات مخصصه لذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه كل هذه الخدمات واكثر
تقدمها رئاسه شؤون الحرمين بالتعاون ايضا
مع الوكالات المسانده والجهات ايضا
الموجوده هنا في الحرم المكي الشريف نتحدث
اليوم بحكم زياده اليوم اعداد الزوار
والمعتمرين عن الخطه التشغيليه الثالثه
التي بدات اليوم بالتزامن مع العشر
الاواخر وايضا خطه التفويج واداره الحشود
هناك خطه محكمه لاداره التفويج والحشود
والجهات الامنيه المشاركه هنا في الحرم
المكي الشريف لاستقبال جميع الحالات وايضا
لتنظيم دخول وخروج المصلين والمعتمرين
ابواب العمره التي فتحت الى يومنا هذا سته
ابواب هي باب الفتح وباب الزبير وباب
السلام وباب الملك عزيز وباب الملك فهد
هناك ايضا سته ابواب مخصصه لدخول المصلين
بالتاكيد انه هذه الخطط ستشهد هذه الايام
بحكم زياده اعداد الزوار المعتمرين خطط
اكثر وتحكيما اكثر نتحدث اليوم ايضا عن
خدمات النقل العام للزوار والمعتمرين هنا
في الحرم المكي واكثر من ثمانيه الاف
حافله متنقله وتردديه من اماكن سكن الزوار
والمعتمرين وايصالهم اليوم الى الحرم
المكي لاداء صلاه التراويح والقيام نتحدث
اليوم ايضا عن ان هذه الخدمات ستزيد في
الايام القادمه سيكون هناك تكثيف في هذه
الخدمات اعداد النترات التي قدمت اليوم
الى الزوار المعتمرين حوالي 26 مليون لتر
وبالتاكيد انها ستزيد في الايام القادمه
اعداد الزوار والمعتمرين اليوم تجاوزت 19
مليون زائر ومعتمر حيث اعلنت الرئاسه ان
في اليوم الواحد تتجاوز اعداد الزوار
المعتمرين 950 الف فاعلى في اليوم الواحد
وبالتاكيد ان هذه نسبه كبيره وستشهد
ازديدا كبيرا وكثافه في اعداد الزوار
والمعتمرين خلال ايام القادمه في العشر
الاواخر شكرا لك مراسل العربيه اسامه
القاسم حدثتنا من مكه المكرمه
اطلقت امانه منطقه المدينه المنوره اعمال
المختبر المنتقل والمتنقل الخاص بفحص جوده
وسلامه الاغذيه والمياه للتاكد من خلوها
من البكتيريا المسببه للامراض ومطابقتها
للمواصفات بهدف ضمان سلامه وجوده الغذاء
المقدم لاهالي وزوار المدينه المنوره طوال
شهر رمضان ويضم المختبر المتنقل للاجهزه
حديثه لفحص المواد الغذائيه في وقت قياسي
[موسيقى]
سلامه الاغذيه والمشروبات اولويه تزيد
اهميتها خلال شهر رمضان وفي خطوه للحد من
تلوث الاطعمه فعلت اماله المدينه المنوره
المختبره المتنقله للتاكد من سلامتها
المتنقل هو عباره عن سياره مزوده باحدث
التقنيات لفحص الملوثات الميكروبيه
والكيميائيه الموجوده في الاغذيه يتم فيه
فحص تقريبا 1500 تعينه في الشهر يتم سحبها
عبر فرق رقابيه مختصه
احضاره للمختبر يتم عليها عمل الفحوصات
اللازمه لكل نوع الهدف طبعا من المختبر
المتنقل هو
الحفاظ على سلامه المواطنين والزوار
وتوفير الامان الغذائي لهم اكثر من مئه
عينه تسحب يوميا من 50 محلا تجاريا للكشف
عليها ويضم المختبر المتنقل اجهزه حديثه
لفحص المواد الغذائيه في وقت قياسي وضمان
خلوها من البكتيريا المسببه للامراض
ومطابقتها للمواصفات الاختبارات التي في
المختبر المتنقل نتائجها تظهر فوريا بمجرد
سحب العينه ووضعها في الجهاز يعطي نتائج
سريعه ودقيقه طبعا احنا قلنا بحملات
توعويه وضحنا لهم الطريقه السليمه لتنظيف
الايدي وزعنا عليهم معقمات خمسه اختبارات
يجريها المختبر المتنقل مثل الكشف عن
عناصر الحديد والكبريت في المياه اضافه
الى السموم الفطريه ومتبقيه المبيدات في
الاغذيه والهدف حياه امنه غذائيا لسكان
وزوار المدينه المنوره من المدينه المنوره
سلطان السلمي العربيه
[موسيقى]
يواصل مسلسل منه ولدنا اثنين كسب ثقه
المشاهد السعوديه والخليجيه على حد سوا اذ
تصدرت مشاهدات المسلسل والنقاشات حول قصته
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي المزيد في فقره
كواليس مع سهى الوعل واعداد ايهم القاسم
[موسيقى]
مو عيب اننا نطيح لكن يلا يا ولد نزل
الشنطه
هلالنا واخيرا القصه التي لا تشبه كل
القصص
[موسيقى]
مرحبا من رمضان الماضي استطاع مسلسل منه
ولدنا انه يصنع لنفسه قاعده جماهيريه
كبيره حيث يقدم جيل تلفزيوني جديد من نجوم
الكوميديا الشباب الجزء الجديد جاء من
زاويه مختلفه فبعد ما كانت القصه تدور فقط
في جزء الاول عن الشابين اتبدل وقت
الولاده وما ترتب على ذلك
ركز الجزء الجديد على امور اخرى كطموحات
كل منهما وكيف دمرت احداهما الاخرى
يعني او انه لازم احنا نصير احسن او هم
يصيرون احسن انا احس كل فريق او كل عمل له
جوا وكل ناس او يعني كل ناس لهم لهم
الاشياء اللي يحبونها
بعمل يعني اتجه الى منحنى مختلف تماما عن
الجزء الاول وبيكون واضح بالنسبه للمشاهد
الجزء الاول ممكن كان التركيز اكثر شي على
الكوميديا بينما الجزء الثاني لا تفرع
وراح اتجاه النصر الى عده امور ولكن ما
تخلو من الكوميديه الكوميديه موجوده ولكن
المستوى الدرامي اصبح اكثر من الكوميديا
ولكن بطريقه لطيفه وخفيفه على المشاهده
المسلسل بحسب تشاهد استطاع انه يحترم مركز
الرابع في السعوديه من ناحيه ارقام
المشاهده اسهم في ذلك بحسب راي النقاط
توقيت عرضه مباشره بعد مسلسل طاش في
الفتره الذهبيه من هو نجاح الموسم الاول
حملنا مسؤوليه كبيره كان نجاح كبير وعظيم
والحمد لله رب العالمين يعني
وصلنا فيه لمناطق كنا حابينه وصلنا لها
فالجزء هذا احنا في مسؤوليه علينا لازم
نكون نقدم افضل
من الجزء الاول فالجزء الثاني في مفاجات
حلوه في احداث جميله في تنوع شخصيات تنوع
احداث
بصراحه عائله وحده ولا قاعد نقدمها جدا
جميل الحمد لله تغير بيني كريان وبين
الاستاذ محمد كان جميل جدا ليش للريال
الموسم الاول كان قاسي معها تماما الين
صار الدرس اللي هو رجع لعالم الفقر ثم رجع
المكان الحقيقي
مع بعض التغريدات من هنا وهناك حول العالم
[موسيقى]
احنا حبيناك عشانك انت
انا حبيتك عشانك انت فلا تغير نفسك عشاني
[موسيقى]
رفع ناشطون فرنسيون لافته احتجاجيه ضد
الرئيس الفرنسي مع خلال زيارته وزياره
رسميه الى هولندا
ورفعت متظاهره لافته تحمل عباره رئيس
العنف حيث القى معكم خطابا تمت مقاطعته من
قبل عده محتاجين عبروا عن امتعاظهم من
الاحداث الاخيره في فرنسا وقد تواجد
محتاجون في خارج القصر الملكي في عام
استردام اثناء مراسم الاستقبال الرسميه
ورفعوا لافتات تعبر عن انهم لن يتراجعوا
انا
[تصفيق]
الحكومه البريطانيه اند باتلر في منصب
مدير جهاز المخابرات العامه لتكون بذلك
اول امراه تشغل المنصب في تاريخ بريطانيا
وقال وزير الخارجيه ان باتلر ساعدت في
التصدي لتهديدات الارهابيين ومرتكبي
الجرائم الالكترونيه والقوى الاجنبيه
الخبيثه ما يجعلها المرشح الامثل لقياده
مقر الاتصالات الحكوميه
ان يكون الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين قد
وصف رجل الاعمال الامريكي ومالك تويتر
ايلون ماسك بمجرم حرب لدعمه اوكرانيا وقال
المتحدث باسم الكرم لانديمتري بسكوب ان
ماسك قد تم تضليله وتم ابلاغه بشكل خاطئ
واضف بسكوب ان قرار رفع الحظر عن تويتر في
روسيا هو ضمن اختصاص الهيئه الفيدراليه
الروسيه للرقابه على الاتصالات
الى ذلك تواجه شركه تسلا الامريكيه دعوه
قضائيه بعد اتهامها بالاهمال والاحتيال
وانتهاك الخصوصيه مع نشر موظفين سابقين
مقاطع مسربه من كاميرات السيارات
الكهربائيه اظهرت مشاهد حساسه لا يحق لها
نشرها باي طريقه كانت ولا حتى التداول
التداول فيها بما بينهم
السياره الحلم بددت اماني الطواقين
لشرائها لانها باختصار باتت مركبات لا
تؤتمن او ربما خارقه ليس لمواصفاتها فائقه
الجوده فحسب وانما لتسللها الى البيانات
بما فيها الشخصيه
اهمال واحتيال وانتهاك للخصوصيه هذا اقل
ما تواجهه الشركه الامريكيه بعد تقرير
لموظفين سابقين في تسلا يقولون ان عدساتها
انتهكت خصوصيه سائقيها فمثلا اضواءها
الاماميه المحشوه بكاميرا مخفيه لا ترصد
الطرقه وحدها وانما كل التحركات حولها اذا
تواجه تسلا دعوى قضائيه رفعها مجموعه
اشخاص بعد تسريب بعض المقاطع التي احتفظت
بها في قواعدها بعضها لمشاهد حساسه ومحرجه
واوردت الدعوه ان التسجيلات المتداوله
كانت شديده الخصوصيه اظهرت عملاء تسلا في
مواقف قد لا يرغبون في نشرها دون موافقتهم
كل لحظه الحميميه او حتى لحوادث اصطدام
جعلت طفلا يطير وليس انتهاء بتحويل صور
كلابهم الى تعليقات ساخره
ويعود تاريخ هذه التصرفات الى عام 2019
بحسب الدعوه التي نادت بوقف هذا السلوك
الجائر ودفع تعويضات لم تحدد بعد تصرفات
وضعت تسلا في مرمى النيران والمحاكم خاصه
وانها اكدت للملايين من مالكي سياراتها ان
خصوصيتهم كانت وستظل دائما مهمه للغايه
والكاميرات مصممه من الالف الى الياء
لحمايتهم
لا نثق بها ولن نستخدمها بتلك الكلمات عبر
المستاون من تسلا رفاهيه وصفت بالمبتذله
رغم كل ميزاتها التكنولوجيه وحتى صديقه
للبيئه فهي على حد وصف الواقعين بين فكي
عدساتها الفارهه الجاسوسه وقبل ايام خفضت
للمره الثالثه سعرها ووسعت مصانعها في
شنغهاي لكنها قد لا تستفيد شيئا اذا لم
تداري فضيحه المقاطع المخجله
[موسيقى]
اعلن برنامج الغذاء العالمي فتح تحقيق في
سرقه مساعدات غذائيه تم توزيعها خلال
العمليات الانسانيه في مناطق النزاع في
اثيوبيا واضف البرنامج ان المساعدات
المسروقه تم العثور على جزء كبير منها في
اسواق المواد الغذائيه
التحقيق في السرقه وبيع مساعدات انسانيه
في اثيوبيا برنامج الاغذيه العالميه
التابع للامم المتحده فتح تحقيقا حول عدم
وصول المساعدات المستحقيها وظهورها في
الاسواق
مدير البرنامج في اثيوبيا كلوجي بيدار قال
ان ظهور المساعدات في بعض الاسواق خطر على
سمعه البرنامج ويهدد قدرته على جمع مزيد
من الموارد من اجل المحتاجين
على ضروره اتخاذ اجراءات فوريه للحد من
اختلاس وسرقه المساعدات الانسانيه في
البلاد فرع برنامج الغذاء في اثيوبيا طالب
المنظمات الشريكه بالابلاغ عن اي معلومات
تتعلق باساءه استخدام الطعام او اختلاسه
برنامج الاغذيه لم يحدد حالات معينه لكن
عمال اغاثه اشاروا الى ان المساعدات سرقت
من بلده شيرارو وتضمنت ما يكفي من الطعام
ل 100 الف شخص
[موسيقى]
حذر مكتبه تحقيقات الفيدراليه من استخدام
شواحن الهواتف العامه المجانيه خوفا من
عمليات اختراق مبتكره عبر منافذ تمنح
usb للمخترقين التجسس على البيانات وكلمات
المرور للهواتف او اجهزه الحاسوب يوصل
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه بانشاء كلمه
مرور قويه وفريده لكل حساب عبر الانترنت
وتغييرها بانتظام
اظهرت مقاطع فيديو طلاب مدارس في المدينه
الباب بمحافظه حلب السوريه التي تخضع
لسيطره فصائل المعارضه صورا لتدافع طلاب
صغار السن امام سور مدرستهم والسبكاء
وصراخ لطلب المساعده بعد هطول امطار غزيره
وتدفق مياه السيول في الشوارع المحيطه
بمدرستهم فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العلوي
موسكو
تتهمرد مسلح داخل روسيا وتوريط الشباب
الروسي في الارهاب
[موسيقى]
مع استمرار التدريبات العسكريه الصينيه
المكثفه تحذيرات من غزو صني محتمل لتايوان
اليوم الخميس يوم 13 من هذا الشهر اول يوم
سوف يكون هنالك عمليه تبادل بين صنعاء
وعدم فراشه مرتقبه للازمه اليمنيه تبادل
الاسره بين الشرعيه والحوثيين يبدا الخميس
والاطباء في بريطانيا يبداون اضرابا جديدا
للمطالبه برفع اجورهم مئات الاف المواعيد
معلقه
مشاهدينا الى هنا اتي الى ختام التاسعه
لكن اخبار العربيه مستمره كما كل ليله
الان الى 360 والزملاء راويه وطاهر مساء
الخير ماذا لديكم مساء الخير مساء الخير
لليال طبعا سنتحدث عن قرار نتنياهو بمنع
الاقتحامات في الايام العشر الاواخر من
شهر رمضان المبارك وايضا الخصوصيه بسيارات
تسلا لا شيء من الانفراج بين الحكومه
اليمنيه والحوثيين على اثر الوساطه التي
تقوم بها المملكه العربيه السعوديه مع
عمان هناك ارجو ان تكوني معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات